was in the new york post and the title
caught my attention i'll never have kids
they're annoying and have no common
sense
now some people feel that way about kids
and they're afraid to say it they're
afraid to say because they're afraid
they're going to be labeled
you know that someone's gonna say oh
she's just selfish or this woman has a
strong opinion let's check it out
laurella palmer that's her she's 22
years old okay so let's take that into
account 22 year old influencer and style
blogger from london
said she doesn't want kids for a variety
of reasons and she's tired of people
trying to change her mind or call her
decision selfish
kids are just annoying they annoy me in
every sense of the word they have no
common sense they can't drink i love
that they can't
drink they have to go to bed early they
scream they cry they annoy me okay every
time i see a child they just got crushed
around their nose and round their mouth
there's drool they've got food
everywhere and they've got sticky
fingers that is true i have a two and a
half year old fingers always sticky that
is true
palmer also had some choice words about
children's television this is the best i
hate kids tv too your kid is one they
don't need to watch cartoons pop on
vampire diaries please or gossip girl or
friends she lamented interesting choice
palmer who recently graduated from the
university of portsmouth with a law
degree said she'd rather focus on
growing her business as an agent for
social media influencers than birthing a
baby she goes on and on and on she does
admit though and this is important
before we converse about it she admitted
she's still young
she could change her mind about having
kids but said people shouldn't put
pressure on women to raise family so
she's acknowledging i'm 22 i might
change my mind now i loved this
column first of all i love that she's
honest
okay agree or disagree this stuff is
hard to say you get ridiculed when you
come out and you say i don't want kids
they're annoying people say oh you're so
selfish you don't have your priorities
there's a lot of stuff that comes your
way and the reason i know it is because
for many years i didn't want kids
i
felt very much about children like that
i was like oh maybe i didn't want to put
friends on for them but i was like i
can't
i can't do what i taught kids i was like
i had a lot of stress around being a mom
i was like i don't know if i'm going to
be a good parent
i feel selfish i kind of want to be
selfish i feel like my whole life's
going to vanish
i
kids used to bug me you know after a day
teaching i'd be like i need to hand them
off to someone i can't do this all night
i was like i'm never gonna sleep again i
had a lot of panic about it and you know
you always think of that kid you meet in
the elevator that presses all the
buttons or they like wipe their nose and
there's like a whole bunch of stuff that
comes with it and then they touch
everything i was that person that was
like listen i don't think this is for me
and i felt that way
through my 20s and my 30s a little bit
of my 30s and
when i would say it to someone they
would be like ah you're so selfish jed
everybody had a line so props to her for
saying it what i will say about this
people at home there may be people at
home that identify with this maybe
people hate her i don't know how you
feel about it let me know in the
comments section how you feel i'm
actually curious
but what i will say is that you change
in life sometimes and sometimes it's
about who you're with and sometimes it's
about the moment of time it is for you i
was not ready to have kids in my 20s
my husband was ready to have kids boom i
met him he was super young he was like i
want a family i want a garage i want a
workbench
i was like what what's a workbench
i was like
i need to get is there like a place to
serve a cocktail i was a very different
person
when i met him
and i
i think you have to respect that about
your journey
right everyone out there listening don't
feel pressure she's right about that
don't feel pressured
you're gonna come to your understanding
of what you want some of you may never
want kids that's okay
that is okay
some of you may not want kids now and
then in 10 years you decide you do
that's okay
some of you may really want kids maybe
you're 22 years old and you're like i
know this is for me this is my calling
that's okay too so we have to learn to
like respect everybody's feelings about
life choices because they're big
decisions and the last thing you want is
somebody having a kid who doesn't want a
kid that's problematic also sometimes it
takes the partner
right
i never met anybody that i wanted to
have it just they didn't inspire that in
me i met jeremy and i was like
i don't know why but all of those fears
about kids turned into excitement about
a child i just felt differently i can't
explain
what it was but you may find that you
feel one way and then you meet someone
and that becomes your partner and you
feel differently allow yourself to be
open
allow you and that's what i love about
the article she's very opinionated but
she's like i don't know how i'm going to
feel in 10 years it would be great if in
10 years she had six kids and wrote an
article about it right
everybody would read that they'd be like
hmm that's kind of cool
so the reason i point this out is
because i feel like in society there's
so much pressure and there's so much
judgment toward everyone so the message
is just let yourself feel what you feel
say it say it out loud
you know say it somebody doesn't like it
too bad that's where you're at on a
tuesday in 2022
it's friday whatever
but it's an important lesson and i
shared that story with you about me
because i have a child and let me tell
you something he is the best thing that
ever happened to me and i love him so
like he literally lights up my whole
life he gave my entire life meaning
jeremy and i always joke we say like
everything has value now in a different
way it's like almost like i everything i
do is for him and he's he's just
everything to me so but i couldn't have
said this at 28 or 22 or 32.
so respect your journey what career kids
whatever it may be and i love that she's
loud about it she's like
that kid picked his nose i'm not doing
it i love it imagine that's hard to say
she probably says that just parents too
sorry your kid
he coughed i'm out you know i love it i
love a ballsy woman if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
you